in this episode of cloud performance
atlas I take a look at a new networking
algorithm that gives your clients a big
performance win is this tech too good to
be true
stay tuned to find out if you follow
along with our content you probably know
that we never advocate for a silver
bullet when it comes to performance
there's always a horde of trade-offs
that you have to consider before things
make sense for your scenario but I'm
going to break my rule this time and say
that you should really be using a new
networking algorithm called TCP bbr
which can give your clients in poor
connectivity areas as much as a 2x boost
in performance and all you have to do is
set a simple server-side flag see TCP as
a protocol tries it's best to balance
between being fast and being fair with
much more emphasis on the being fair
part for example as packet loss on your
network increases TCPS back off
algorithm will reduce the performance of
each user so that everyone can share the
pipe but fine-tuning this balance is
really tricky with TCP s current back
off algorithms even if you're the only
person using the pipe it can under
utilize your network connection by as
much as 50 percent this is where TCP bbr
comes in it's an updated back off
algorithm that's designed to respond to
actual congestion rather than just
simple packet loss which means that it's
focused on improving network performance
in the worst case scenario when your
network isn't very good now sadly I
don't have access to a consistently
unstable Network so for the sake of our
tests we're going to simulate some
worst-case scenarios to test things I
set up two VMs in two different regions
one to be the client and one to be to
server and did a quick iperf test to
check out their performance then to
simulate our unstable Network we run the
following TC command on the client which
will reduce performance by increasing
packet loss re running the tests we see
that this has a dramatic impact on our
performance now that we know what our
performance looks like in the
problematic scenario we enable bbr on
the server and we see that our
performance more than doubles and to be
clear we only have to set this flag on
the server TCP bbr doesn't require the
client to have the same bb our
implementation running meaning that your
legacy clients can get this
Busse without needing an update not bad
for a day's work if you'd like to know
more details about bbr check out the
Related article linked in the
description below and don't forget to
check out the rest of our cloud
performance Atlas content because when
it comes to performance every
millisecond counts